théâtre avec le retour de godo même si
les spectateurs sont condamnés à
l'attendre une des plus grandes pièces
de ce siècle est à nouveau à l'affiché à
paris le texte se mêlent beckett à
garder intact sa force sa poésie une
réflexion centrée surtout sur le
désespoir de la condition humaine
dominique poncet et marque sa vie dans
ces eaux m'a dit de vous dire qu'il ne
viendra pas ce soir mais sûrement demain
c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas d'intrigué
dit je suis content je suis content
les gens sont très surpris très
intéressé choc est bouleversée de voir
des individus qui attendent sur un
plateau aujourd'hui oubliée en 1953 la
générale d'en attendant godot partisans
et adversaires de la pièce un marteau
main mais dès la deuxième représentation
la pièce fit l'unanimité car c'était la
première du xxème siècle à dire avec
autant d'acuité et de drôlerie aussi
l'absurdité de la condition humaine
il faut dire qu'elle était signé d'un
orfèvre en la matière
samuel beckett il en va de même du
risque
c'est le jeu de variations comme il joue
sur la variation à l'infini c'est un peu
le système de la cantate ou l'art de la
fugue en est content donc évidemment ça
crée aussi un système d'humour à tiroirs
c'est à dire ce donc le spectateur et et
complice de cet humour la question qui
laquelle tout à l'heure vous me disiez
monsieur en tremblant maintenant vous me
posez des questions
ça va mal fini je ne crois pas qu'on
peut tout saisir pendant qu'on la voit
mais je crois que ça travaux elle après
dans les rêves et dans la conscience a
fait un énorme travail cps gotoh viendra
sûrement demain ça te dire alors y'a
plus qu'à mais tu es fou sur le plateau
du théâtre de l'odéon en attendant godot
se joue avec une humanité bouleversante
et en même temps comme en état de grâce
si samuel beckett avait encore été là il
aurait été probablement contents